just runs up guy see what's going on Oh
buddy listen mate you know this is never
a good idea
Oh God yeah oh I'm out oh yeah right
behind me
full of beer Dark Souls absolutely love
it sci-fi
yep what you know is a game this melded
those two worlds tam sounds brilliant
they fit with a more he's sane play in
the surge it's a all right so if I play
like two or three hours I've died a
bunch I've got some parts it's pretty
good time this is developed by Dec 13
who just probably start recording I
pointed out has already made their Dark
Souls esque game yeah this one's better
than the last one yeah
other blood of the Fallen was okay this
is this is better than okay yeah
I've enjoyed this like there's a lot of
clever things and so you're you've got a
job at the comfort this company that's
supposed to be saving the world and I'm
not gonna spoil anything but they're not
quite saving the world
so probably aside I'm going to recycle
some parts and get a new head piece
because your your suits your exoskeleton
power loader basically is all like
customizable so in public box VR headset
I'm gonna put like a gear via on my eyes
to give me a little more damage how can
I give you more damage just Mobley
blaming you protection okay this is this
is the first area and it does the same
things that Dark Souls do so like you
have the path there that comes around
and then I'll open a shortcut for you to
get back and it starts open sprawling
but this is like the first area you'll
come to right and I'll give you a little
demonstration the combat it's a nice
looking area is it sim looks quite nice
it's very colorful it does so
interesting things so you see this guy I
can target different parts of his body
no if it's in blue means that an
unarmored don't do more damage if it's
in yellow it means it's armored but if I
attack that one piece it gives me a good
chance to get it so that's how you get a
lot of the new armor pieces and new
weapons great one piece reference there
no it's just you said the words one
piece oh hey trades lot of reference so
say I wanted this guy's drill wherever
he's got his arm yeah if I do a bunch of
damage to the drill and
do the special move to cut the actual
thing off I'm in with the decent chance
to get the drill so I didn't get the
drill but I did get a rekt part of his
art okay so I did get something out of
it so it's not guaranteed drop a
guaranteed drop but the more damage you
do to a limb the higher the chance you
get that drop right but each enemy has a
limited health poor rose so yeah
I wanted to get that special move we cut
them off you have to fill in your energy
meter which is under the stamina at the
top left
does that work the same for bosses I've
only fought one boss
actually but as you bring up boss this
isn't the way you usually go I've done
this area so we're going to start off
the let's play instead of finishing with
the boss we're going to try and start
with the bus see the reason why I ask is
it makes me think of like if you could
target a specific area of a boss and
then try and get a loot drop out of it
it sounds like it'll be quite inspired
by the gargoyles in Dark Souls yeah you
could go for the tail and get the ex
yeah I've not seen anything like that so
far the only boss I've found is by this
Walker thing where you can like targets
legs right and well I'll show you I'll
show you the boss how does it feel to
control because Dark Souls has a lot of
heft to it whereas this this seems a
little slightly a little bit it's got um
some of the things like interrupting
your own attacks or to dodge right isn't
quite as it just feels different from
Dark Souls like obviously Dark Souls
your guy in armor this is the you are a
mech suit because I think that the
heaviness is in relation to that alright
so this is the first boss this giant
mech dude I thought his name is his name
is like pax east or south just packs but
what you need to do is like a security
robot for the Penny Arcade Expo yeah for
the Penny Arcade I need to fill up his
aggro meter the the yellow bar and then
he starts to lose his mind from shoot
missiles at me right he goes rampant
like goes on basically and when they
shoots the missiles I need to kite the
missiles they hit
it's going to be the boss I mean that's
a that's an interesting wrinkle to the
gameplay instead of the traditional just
hack Atlas boss well this this is the
first part this is the first god kept
close enough this is the first boss I
fall and it's like a man I was like this
mother lover isn't taking any damage
right what do I do
so I probably fought this boss probably
like 15 times right I had much more luck
with a Titan ID man the first time I
fought him but this seems like there
might be a trend where there's a trick
to every boss possibly it doesn't do the
dark souls thing of light attack and
heavy attack instead l1 and playing a PC
but with the ps4 controller l1 is a
horizontal attack o r1 is a vertical
attack that kind of makes sense if
you're if it has the mechanical you're
specifically targeting limbs and yeah
yeah get your own missiles in your mouth
and you can you can charge those attacks
up as well right so I'm noticing so far
is the evasive maneuvers they very much
like hops and side dashes and yeah
there's no there's no rolls yeah so it
feels as a one the one hand it feels
more active but on the other hand it
doesn't feel as like kind of cool and
grounded there's something I like the
heft of the rolls yeah but this does
give it like a kind of like back step
type because because you're always going
to be heavy since you're wearing parts
of robots yeah it's not going to be
becomes fat roll from why I've been
playing the Kama a little bit and it's
never really explained but I feel like
this combos like I'm just I'm just like
smashing buttons but everyone again
it'll do what appears to be like a
special move
I did like a Creole hit in his leg then
I think which many just collapsed it sir
it's like an interesting story behind
this other than me you're supposed to be
saving yes no but is it like Dark Soul
stole there's more to this world than
you can yeah very much so so I the game
starts off and very slight spoilers but
something that just kind of caught me
off guard you start the game and you're
actually in a wheelchair oh and it's
this method this is suit that actually
gives you the ability to walk again
then the fastest and the first time I
brought up beat that bus I love that the
moment you get this ability to walk
again you immediately get to Smashing
things so you wake up and these robots
are trying to salvage you you've been
taken Quaqua offline and you just used
under attack straight away hmm
um and you've woken up you get this
mysterious voice that says you need to
escape you need to do this and that's
that's really as much as I know there's
that the company isn't all what it seems
like you're led to believe that this
company she's quite an ironing board on
yeah it's the comply your let's believe
this company like wants to save the
world and then you wake up in an area
like full of corpses and everything's
trying to kill you so something's not
right
have you met any interesting NPCs here
though no I've not met any NPCs other
than like one that was just a voice that
came from like a computer it's
interesting I wonder like it I I can't
help but compare it to Dark Souls yes
the same can I have a comparison I mean
it where's docking at Harrison directly
honestly yeah at the same time it could
be a pitfall like I do am I expecting
the same things as doctors that should
there be an NPC is it is there up on
fire equivalent there is a bonfire
equivalent and there are NPCs so that
area that I was in at the start that is
kind of the equivalent unifier from now
like a workshop style thing yeah and I
know there are quest giver NPCs that you
can kill and accidentally ruin your game
do you get to turn the light on the
workshop when you enter which means in
the lab I'm trying to figure out a way
of transplanting the bonfire lit bonfire
set oh I definitely know someone needs
to come up with a rhyme for this game
with this this is literally far as I've
gone now like this I'm going to be
seeing all this stuff alongside you that
boss was where I was stuck okay but
killed that boss I have no idea where to
go now so we're going to explore and see
can you jump you can jump you get late
it's got the horrible Dark Souls one
thing okay of running and then hitting
the Run button again or is the delay as
well there's a slight delay okay so I
this I've this this is my objective to
get on the maglev train and get
somewhere else so new area yeah this is
going to be a new area the arrows in it
had an open way kind of led back on
itself when you open shortcuts fighting
crime fighting shock it's gonna be a no
new Honda Donnell Londo there's a two
different places on all the way new
londo just smashed into one oh it's just
a Westfield Mall so the coolest part the
game start was case his creo I mean a
guy who tries to sell crea not just
another company our founder Jonah
Guttenberg has a vision a vision
outsider war classic youtuber a what a
[ __ ] boy we show a Creole shell 26
we're gonna do another unboxing the
start of the game was M was very
interesting event I've only skipped
ahead because you know thought it'd be
interesting to see a little bit more but
from the start of the game you're in the
wheelchair and the way you pick your
class is you just pick a job no do you
want to there's only two
like links where you're fast and Rhino
we're a bit tankier I started out as
links but a lot the equipment I've got
on is is Rhino hmm don't know it's
Jerome which doesn't mean that is like a
disadvantage to all like is there a
penalty for having a different job from
the rental equipment nation I think
that's I don't know this is I think it
is that that just gives you your
starring gear like there's no stats that
you can agree that you can't upgrade
like a stamina it I spent a year
around Sky's dead drones hang out show
me around around SiC pants just buzz it
off to get it this looks like maybe I
need I need a drone for some places to
get through but he unlock this elevator
you just unlocked it by smashing himself
into it you can use companions or unique
combat actions for dro modules okay so
it's like I've actually got a new button
the triangle button to do something
sweet look broken parts you Salvage for
four pieces to build and upgrade new
stuff okay so this is my range attack I
was wondering if I'd ever get a range
attack because the range enemies were
real strong they were ruining me but if
I've got like a drone range attack now
oh you can see his eyes underneath there
ya go via was really gross is the back
of his head there's a cutscene to start
the game where he gets the the exosuit
attached to him and it's so gross yeah
it's also like scars and cuts on the
back of his head when and oh you actual
pew pew I'm a fan of that so it looks
like it's just on a time thing right
much environment or storytelling in this
there's a lot of like things like
graffiti okay and soon I saw that like
guy talking about Cree or whatever yeah
so I guess can't you see guys in
uniforms that all messed up and stuff
there was a door back there I just went
through this one I don't know if this is
the right way again that Dark Souls
thing good oh this is the new bonfire ah
keeping it to turn alone so I think to
start you need to get in the medbay
and you can spend points to increase
your power core level but these two
these like your souls Ram your Tex crap
but unlike Dark Souls you can actually
just bank them so you don't lose them oh
so they're just dead just in there now
I've unlocked a new slot
these are these are how you customize
your character these are your implants
so I could rip job yeah that's going to
be my next implant I didn't want to hit
help and hit sort so you can sort them
by marks but this one this one costs for
power but I've only got two power
available to me right so I could
probably put in increase increase to
maximum health let's do that what's that
bar on the bottom left is obviously your
weapon proficiency yeah that's a the
more you use a certain type of weapon
the more weapon proficiency you get in
different weapons scale differently with
your proficiency
this one is looks fairly generic does it
like three on two yeah so this is this
is a two-handed weapon I'm level four in
two-handed okay so it's not per weapon
it's per class or per class yeah so
that's that's a two-handed weapon
between rigged this is one-handed this
is simple rig single rigged so but you
can see on the stats and proficiency
scaling very low meaning that the worst
my proficiency is mia lewis who makes it
but this weapon i found at the boss
looks great so i'm just going to rock
with this you can get like a dental
records as well things that you can do
special moves and whoa should have
expected that really a dark cells like
proper hiding behind that column i
haven't done much in the way of blocking
i don't think it you can you can block
but oh god he just murdered me straight
away so you can block in this game you
can't move and block wait okay what I
used to do in Dark Souls to have your
dodge so it makes the combat a little
more harrowing but if you time a block
well that you can even counter it does
your roll / - have invincibility frames
on it I've not looked close enough to
see actual invincibility frames but I
mean I'm wondering if it if it doesn't
really want you to use your blocking as
much as I want to
maneuver around and fur yeah well from
what I saw it I think I thought links
class and Rhyno classes with dependent
on stuff like that right there doesn't
seem to be like poise in this one a
giant dog solid interrupts an attack
buys out poising them yeah people can
still like attack through your attacks
it's never explained why the respawn
thing happens either so in dog collars
obviously when you rekindle the fire
things respawn yeah does the same thing
but doesn't explosion doesn't say why
like from what I could tell this is just
a mad dude that's stuck inside of his
mech yeah screaming like a maniac it's
quite unsettling and once I get his
hammer
due to a power outage we are unable to
provide full circuit so I did just get
his hammer did I yeah oh yeah yeah there
is that's like a heavy duty that's a new
class of weapon though scaling bellows
scaling this one does like fat damage so
I'm gonna stick with this one yes this
is how it kind of this this this is a
mechanic that gates you somewhat so I
needed to be at least power level 10 to
open that and I was obviously way above
that but in the future I'm assuming that
I find things that way higher power
level and I'll needs upgrades so you
couldn't get into that area without that
without being power level 10 by M so now
I can actually assemble gear
what would this weird like truck stop
yeah that I actually hate that about
this game it has a weird country music
soundtrack in these workshops and it's
like the same song again again it's
going for the ax Starcraft 2 yeah
brain brain ax angle you well you
finally tell me who you are on that was
an hour for his name nice Ally
so this this the woman that sent me that
message I don't know why she's trying to
help me but just trying my best to
figure out how I can something's
obviously gone wrong she's mad South
Africa's going on yeah that's what I
know
that's terrible accent haunt man every
time everything looks like our girl
accent comes up you have to say prawns
and then that reminds me the district 10
hasn't happened and it makes me sad
alright fine Oh at least I mean at least
the main characters a chatty dude yeah
yeah I like options
on our own and there are embassies that
I think you can rescue and write
questions above yeah and I saw I saw a
clip the twitch stream was playing this
and he accidentally killed to quest
givers by doing an aerial to area attack
in the the hub a little bit like does it
do this thing worth saving so
oh yeah it's constantly saving so once
you've done it once you've done it - yes
the executive man sounds really sad
that's so upset yeah some of the audio
logs are like yo stuffs getting real
messed up we need help we're in time
that's square only pops up after you've
got enough energy and then it doesn't
start draining it it'll drain it when
you do a special attack and I'll drain a
time if you don't use up your energy
okay
that's interesting get'em drum just agro
it's a great way of you are growing X
you don't have life so it's the
equivalent of a stone isn't it from Dark
Souls pretty much a shootin enemy with a
bow from far away there or blood-borne
had stones didn't ya true
can his boxes you scrub deliver yourself
to a different Department so I should
pick up I just picked up some some gear
and when you set when you go back to
base you can salvage those for a force
regulator mark one and then reuse it to
make new stuff
oh is that zapping whoa see a new enemy
I use a spear type I don't know if this
is someone in a Mac or like a security
guard he does a lot of damage
whoa he's hot you call his boys you are
low on health
Oh ditch boys boys corners all these
boys these sons do a lot of damage fam
is there Perry Jesus Wow
um I think if you block and attack quick
enough you kind of repulse or trap area
you do a little bit of extra damage I
don't know if they'll always go that way
if you are dead alarm is going off maybe
I maybe I'm not supposed to go that way
does those guys have hefty
no map no map you can download these
you've got like a general one I think
I'm I've just miss remembered that I'm
gonna go to the right this time and just
ignore those guys a time being
Oh hear that beep was it means a secret
it boy that is so videogame me I kind of
love it
to be honest though like icon I must say
that that beeping thing to hold to find
secrets is a pre-order bonus really yeah
otherwise you just you just lost secrets
as in you cousin you can't it just won't
make that beeping noise it just might
make the beeping noise and that's the
suit upgrade presumably yeah so I lose a
slot by using that ok so there's some
sort I don't know if I like that but I
guess it's it's optional yeah so this
guy I can overcharge a suit to help him
this is the first other person I found
Dean Hobbes Dean Hobbes
I'm a boy so that's something good no I
like it soon as our battery come on damn
thank you Quartey yeah can't count how
many times I've had Lee's Mayenne nearly
piss my pants please smash uh are you
here what are you doing down here
no just come on don't let me down let's
audios yeah [ __ ] to think find out
what's going on here
stupid man just stupid wanted to check
just a jumpstart man is is just like
skipping now maybe that's Paul the story
maybe everyone's like he's nuts yet can
the crazy I'm gonna feel safe with these
failsafe consoles Krios got a few around
of fact we're sure to be some crate
height
there's just messages but my adventure
and days are done I'm trying to work out
how to get him back to the to filing try
felt like my brain was an egg so his I
think hit what happened to him is the
same thing happened to me just woke up
right what's your plan
to get my ass out of here before you go
head up to ops okay so that Ops is where
Ops is the fire blood man
so I'm assuming next time I respawn
he'll be proper hey Annie
I can't get back see if I can do a drop
attack yeah Oh network hey buddy
Oh golly
beeping was going nuts then yeah
actually my disabled it is quite
annoying yeah I love how Kenya is Jesus
these nuts these nuts these guys these
these guys with the double arms are nuts
and I love that a Freudian slip
accidentally too many memes in the
morning man too many memes to you many
means we need some wholesome tweets in
here I got laser it's got something his
arm I think he's just standing really
close some environment stuff oh no sir
oh wow
stun locked for days okay I'm - show
through walk Oh mate relax
so that hammer there you can shoot with
it we told me that well so you see that
kick that's that's like that one okay
you see the thing I mean about them that
they can quite easily attack you through
your attack right right so you're not
interrupting animations yeah which was a
which is a big thing in dark so properly
timed there is see my boy we made it
buddy
good to see you I don't like him you
think he's like he uses body way too
much you just gave me he's a he's a lot
trek on this game he's gonna make about
yes goodbye
did we did just give me a load of stuff
so did patches look um great this OH
upgrading my big weapon patches
o'houlihan thing I can upgrade patches
o'houlihan rating my eyes advice from
dodgeball applies to Dark Souls as well
yep remember George duck dip dive and
dodge it's very true
yah repeater I've noticed I don't know
if this is a fault for me for not just
playing Dark Souls in a long time I've
noticed I've not been paying much
attention to my stamina yeah but I
really know Lane the game for that
that's like my own foible gotta train
yourself to back into the ER yeah slowly
been doing that bird Hey the error sound
is someone else me it's without only
that one enemy this is the missile for
the higher hammer it looked like it was
attached to something behind him there's
a lot of bleepy blooping noises in this
game yeah I'm actually going to throw
casino ask disable a secret finding
implant and put and I think in its
placing huh huh
that costs no power that's why I can use
it but it's annoying so I'll just
disable it for now
also there's no downside to using it no
except this yeah listen annoying
annoying AF so now that is drone I'm
just cutting every enemy away from
wherever they are because I don't trust
ya should go for a body body kill take
it up bodies
it's 2002 again best you so that song is
a jet leaves the one you would bring up
Jet Li's the one gray film well ok great
multiverse idea go around kill yourself
to become the one oh you got it all so
Gabriel you law is a great name for a
character how do you have such great
memory about just these obscure films
just love that film that exactly the one
thing was little body to the floor in
the garage scene is excellent I mean if
you go back and watch it now because the
visual effects are hilariously bad like
superb ever back in a day or so
Oh with kind of councilors Rahm tak now
I think that was just that was a great
emotion how big is his hitbox like a
tower just goes up is the sky infinitely
that guy nearly killed me yeah got his
Wolverine going started his steps
am I going what are using to recover was
the item for recovery it's just called
an injectable and you can actually
unequip those or equip different types
of injectable so these implants here
that is called vital boosts I don't know
they're not they're called vital
injections and they restore eighty
health but you get an install ones the
buff health over time right now yeah so
injectable regenerates health over 30
seconds and I've only got six because
I've taken up two implants lots for them
right yellow bloody hell
oh okay
it's nice about this game is it doesn't
have the gross enemies like Dark Souls
pass I was going to say like everything
looks kind of robotic and stare are
weird occasionally like this dude looks
a bit weird but otherwise fairly
standard wonder if you'll start
introducing that stuff later on it could
be a story thing right may be welcomed
by enemies I've seen so far are all like
main humans it's stuck inside their
necks but what if there's
experimentations where flesh is being
combined with machine no you're not but
I do
let's keep playing to find out okay wait
it's actually a tough enemy with
scorpions already come nearly out of
ester stir my injectables
ranae's up guy see what's going on oh
listen mate you know this is never a
good idea
oh god yeah I'm out oh yeah the probably
out meat is a la oh no it's not anyway
my eggs are lift get me open I think
that the only thing that was there was
just dis a dead end dead end
Oh Russell I think we've lost our tech
scrap though rip let's have a look in
this area before we call it Oh we'll go
for these two enemies and then we'll
call it a day I think we've shown off a
good a good amount of what's interesting
yeah agent research it's I'm always keen
to check out Dark Souls flavoured games
and this one's this does have a lot of
Dark Souls flavor but it's also not been
afraid to add its own yeah and also the
thematic difference like Lords of the
Fallen is the last major like triple-a
Doc's all-star game I'm trying this you
guys also made yeah and but like that
had a very kind of similar aesthetic
it's not proper medieval as like Norse
and that kind of stuff but yeah a lot of
the same feeling this is very very
different by the gameplay play wrinkle
of actually dismembering enemies to get
stuff I think is really interesting it
makes you fight a different way Oh laddy
al so
I'm fully aware that I could do more
damage if I hit his head but I wouldn't
get anything good out of it yeah well we
died one too many times you died you you
died just overlay that that's been the
surge hope you guys enjoyed if you did
make sure hit the like button subscribe
down below if you've been playing a
surge are you planning on it let us know
what you think of it we've got a review
coming out of it very soon to keep an
eye on our youtube channel for that and
like I said if you enjoyed like bun and
we will see you next time bye goodbye
this I hate the song though they leave
the song